ladies and gentlemen it is a great honor
to give the commencement address at this
College an institution that has for a
century and a half been an inspiring
example not only to the people of
Michigan but to America as a whole
Hillsdale was already flourishing in the
days of the Civil War when the college
distinguished itself in the fight
against slavery and is flourishing today
when it has led the fight against the
new kind of slavery imposed by the state
it is I have to say somewhat astonishing
to be standing here today addressing a
free institution devoted to the ideals
of academic life which has resolutely
refused to conform to any purpose other
than its own it is no longer widely
assumed that institutions and gatherings
are legitimate until they have been
subjected to some government program we
live in a world in which minorities
impose their will through law and
censorship of course they are not the
old minorities of landowners and slave
drivers there are minorities that Oh
their status to the state rather than to
society liberal professors lobbyists
tireless agitators determined to impose
their values on the rest of us usually
in the name of some other minority to
which they do not belong but whose
disadvantages they appropriate as badges
of Honor I don't think I need to remind
you of the phenomenon or of the damage
that it is doing to the American culture
of responsibility and enterprise but
maybe it would be appropriate at this
happy event to say something about the
kind of education that Hillsdale stands
for and its utility in the world to
which we belong for it is thanks to
institutions like Hillsdale that
academic freedom and respect for
intellectual tradition still exist in
America even though they are rapidly
disappearing elsewhere the liberal arts
college is a specifically American
institution there
a few private universities scattered
around Europe Oxford and Cambridge are
still nominally independent of the
British government though increasingly
dependent upon it for funds but
institutions devoted purely to
implanting knowledge in young minds in
which curriculum conduct and ethos are
entirely subordinate to that aim no
longer really exist in Europe everywhere
we sense the long arm of the state and
at the head of that arm a bureaucracy
that has social engineering rather than
knowledge as its governing concern
thanks to the liberal arts tradition
free scholarship has been maintained in
America and I would like to say
something today about what that really
means for a long time we in Europe have
been told that the knowledge and skills
imparted to our children should be
relevant and that the test of a relevant
curriculum is that it should benefit the
students who are studying it but when
universities were founded it was with
quite another aim in view they were
founded in order to enhance and
propagate knowledge and the knowledge in
question was regarded as valuable for
its own sake whether or not if we put to
any immediate use knowledge was not a
benefit conferred on students rather
students were a benefit conferred on
knowledge they were the means whereby
knowledge could be passed on the
instrument for transferring to the next
generation a precious legacy acquired
from the last that is as it should be
and as it still is I believe in an
institution like this I'm not saying
that the school is more important than
the student I'm saying that the school
and the student must work together to
advance a shared aim and that aim is not
pleasure or career or social engineering
but knowledge there are good things that
we obtain only if we aim at them and
work for them but there are other good
things that we obtain only if we don't
aim at them and don't work for them
exclusively success comes to those who
put other values above it values like
honesty probity responsibility and the
affections of private life and one of
the values on which success depends is
knowledge often you will hear it said
that our curriculum is antiquated that
the subjects taught are irrelevant that
new skills and new knowledge need to be
imparted and so on and of course it is
true that the knowledge that is stored
and taught in universities and colleges
must always be updated indeed that is
one of the functions of an institution
like this one to ensure not just that
old knowledge is retained but also that
new knowledge is added however you
cannot know in advance what will or will
not be relevant to the future needs of
society nor can you invent knowledge
before you have discovered it it is only
by reflecting on a given store of
knowledge and attempting to enlarge and
improve it that we can really understand
what we are doing when we teach in a
college here is an example in the early
19th century university education in my
country in Britain was largely centered
on classical languages and theology many
people had difficulty in understanding
why the civil service should be
recruiting people whose knowledge
concerned languages that could not be
spoken and worlds that could not be seen
but when in a fit of absence of mind
the British acquired an empire it was
just those people who had the knowledge
required to govern it graduates in the
old classical curriculum were familiar
with pagan myths and tribal societies
they could feel their way into social
worlds where the supernatural was
inextricably entwined with the natural
they had the discipline needed to pick
up languages where the dead liked
Sanskrit or living like Hindi or Yoruba
it was British civil servants not native
Indians who began the movement to revive
classically
in music and who collected and restored
so much at the Sanskrit heritage and
thanks to their knowledge which many
people had regarded as entirely
irrelevant to the progressive times in
which they lived a mere thousand British
civil servants educated largely in Latin
and Greek were able to govern the entire
subcontinent I could mention other
examples the irrelevant seeming science
of formal logic which grew from abstract
questions in philosophy led at last to
the computer revolution the armchair
study of Livy Tacitus and Cicero endowed
us with the concepts that shaped the
American Constitution but maybe the
point does not need insisting on
knowledge becomes useful to us
unpredictably and it is useful only
because it is knowledge rather than
opinion or propaganda relevance should
not be a concern of the true Academy for
what is relevant changes from day to day
and unpredictably
whereas knowledge is permanent and never
loses its worth but how do we
distinguish knowledge from opinion how
in particular do we distinguish the two
in those areas like the traditional
humanities where there is no scientific
method this question troubled Plato and
inspired him to found the Academy over
two million millennia ago and the
question remains with us today in recent
years we have witnessed a crisis in the
humanities that has had serious
repercussions not only in universities
but also in the surrounding culture many
people have lost confidence in the claim
of the traditional humanities to embody
knowledge and have therefore begun to
wonder whether it is to anyone's benefit
that we go on making a place for these
subjects in the academic curriculum if
the only thing you learn from your
courses in literature is how to ape the
political opinions of the professor then
it could well be that your parents were
damn fools to spend a quarter of a
million dollars required for your
college education this problem is
especially urgent for a
like this one what after all do we mean
by the liberal arts if not the study of
the many ways in which the human spirit
has sought to express and endorse itself
in artistic cultural and political
traditions and young people come to
college both eager to acquire the
culture of their community and curious
about the culture of everywhere else for
many of them the three or four years of
college are the one occasion in a
lifetime to acquire knowledge and
insight into the human condition to
become at home in the world of ideas and
to learn that most important of all
abilities which is the ability to read a
book in the light of this the humanities
cannot fail to be of the first
importance for an institution like
Hillsdale College since they are the
primary way in which an inherited
culture is preserved and passed on and
an opening for the mass of young people
to the life of the mind when we look at
what is taught in the name of the
humanities at many of our universities
the Ivy League colleges included we find
ourselves often both disappointed and
alarmed disappointed at the decline in
serious knowledge and alarmed at what is
being put in its place we have seen the
emergence of courses indeed whole
subjects in which the purpose is not
dispassionate inquiry but ideological
conformity one in particular that has
swept through academic academies to sort
has swept through American academies
with a speed that is itself a sign of an
ideological rather than an intellectual
purpose is Women's Studies which I'm
glad to say has no place at Hillsdale
College as christina hoff sommers
summers has shown in our many writings
the majority of courses in women's
studies are really tests of ideological
conformity it doesn't matter what you
know at the end of such a course but
rather what your opinions are on the
issues that concern the modern feminist
you have got to subscribe to a raft of
political attitudes and to support those
attitudes with whatever pseudo
scholarship becomes too
and you have to study our culture
civilization and history in a state of
paranoid suspicion that it was all
really a conspiracy against women and if
you diverge from the official doctrine
this is pretty sure to be reflected in
your grade this is not to say that there
is no benefit to be gained from studying
the way in which the position of women
in society has been reflected in art and
literature down the centuries there are
interesting intellectual questions here
but the thought that you can gain
insight into those questions simply by
the study of women and with the
ideological blinkers of the modern
feminists pinned firmly to your head is
not just unlikely it involves assuming
as the premise of your study what also
the best to be a conclusion and one that
you should be free to reject which
involves putting the unquestionable in
place of the question the existence of
such pseudo subjects creates a further
problem over and above the growing heap
of intellectual garbage for what happens
to the graduates that emerge from such a
study what do they go on to do in life
well one thing they can do is teach and
that is what they will do if they can
hence once a pseudo subject exists it
will rapidly spread through the
educational system rotting the minds of
adolescents and children right down to
the very lowest grade in school that is
one reason why hard subjects with real
intellectual discipline is attached to
them are disappearing from our schools
for society is undersupplied with people
able to teach them and oversupplied with
people who want to teach something else
and whose sites are fixed on the
opinions rather than the knowledge of
the young ideology is one threat to
humane education pseudoscience and
pseudo theory another for this too is a
sign of a loss of confidence literature
music art history and political science
are vehicles of knowledge but it is not
scientific knowledge and cannot be
contained in a theory when people lose
sight of this knowledge or lose
confidence in the belief that is Israeli
knowledge rather than the cast-off
opinions of dead white European males
they look around those cells for some
method with which to approach it
approach it
they bury their confusion under a mound
of pseudo technicalities and borrowed
jargon and pretend to themselves but
they have put what was previously empty
speculation on a more scientific or
theoretical footing and very often the
devices that appeal to them are adopted
for their subversive potential the
science is chosen in order to destroy
the moral credentials of the subject
matter rather than to relate to it as
ours
hence the absurdist philosophy of
deconstruction has swept through
humanities departments in America not
because it has any foundation foundation
in truth but because it promises to
debunk whatever it is applied to and can
therefore be used to cast off our
cultural inheritance and release
relieve us of the burden of transmitting
it ideology and pseudoscience have not
yet triumphed and Hillsdale is one
inspiring sign of this this College has
stayed true to the belief that the
humanities remain central to academic
life
Hillsdale reminds us that while young
people need factual knowledge they need
moral knowledge to true humane education
involves an education of the sympathies
and an imaginative awareness of the
human condition in its completeness it
requires an openness to experience that
is the very opposite of the ideological
dogmatism that is increasingly required
of the young and it is acquired by the
long slow process of critical reflection
this process underpins such subjects as
art history English and musicology
critical reflection does not ask you to
renounce all judgment or opinion but it
asks you to recognize the distinction
between informed opinion and mere
ideology it can be imparted only where a
firm and
during a curriculum is maintained in
being by people whose understanding is
constantly refreshed by the study of the
enduring monuments of our culture to
define and defend humane education so
understood is one of the great
challenges faced by our cadet academies
in our time to stack's to places like
Hillsdale that this challenge is still
understood and is still being met by so
many devoted and responsible teachers
those who graduate from such a college
take with them into the world a body of
useful knowledge and an awareness of the
real distinctions between knowledge and
opinion and between scholarship and
ideology they will serve as guiding
lights to those around them and will
possess a moral and intellectual
inheritance that they can pass on to the
generations on whom our future depends
long may Hillsdale continue the good
work of producing those graduates and so
pointing the way forward for the Academy
as a whole thank you
[Applause]
on behalf of the faculty and the Board
of Trustees of Hillsdale College it is
my privilege to present to you Roger
Scruton the honorary degree of Doctor of
Humane Letters
[Applause]
[Music]
apparently Professor Scruton was very
good on a YouTube video too and senior
class officers and I were like we're not
even correct about him Thank You
professor very much lawrence and valerie
bullying hail from Jackson Michigan
up that way where it's raining Lawrence
is a graduate of Jackson junior college
and the University of Michigan and it's
law school he served in the army and he
practiced law he has helped to found the
Jackson Community College he was
chairman and board member of just about
every major charity in that city and
indeed in this region including
especially the Jackson Symphony
Orchestra where he first got to know Jim
Holloman and the foot Memorial Hospital
he is won every award that city has to
give Valerie is a retired German teacher
and she too forms the bedrock of their
city and their region she is an advisors
and scholarship administration to the
University of Michigan and she's on half
the boards in town Lawrence is the
chairman of the weather X Foundation
they have been in generous with the
college especially in the sciences and
music and the Hillsdale Academy and the
Kirby Center at Washington those two
have been married nearly 60 years they
have four children and eight
grandchildren and I've known them for 12
years and I've always found them funny
kind intelligent perceptive full of good
advice and also very generous please
welcome them to the podium
[Applause]
on behalf of the faculty in the board of
trustees of Hillsdale College it is my
privilege to present to you Lawrence and
Valerie Bullen the honorary degree
Doctor of public service
[Applause]
[Applause]
Jan Sherman Hemsley was born in New York
City she attended Skidmore and as a
graduate of Hunter College in Manhattan
she holds the master's degree in public
administration from the American
University in Washington she has
consulted with the Johns Hopkins Applied
Physics Laboratory and managed at the
accounting firm peat Marwick with her
husband howard she has a keen interest
in art and music howard also was born in
new york he graduated from Columbia and
from the New York College of Dentistry
he was a captain in the United States
Army and he was stationed in Washington
DC when he had the good fortune to meet
Jan he practiced industry and served on
the faculty of the Howard University
College of Dentistry Howard and Jan will
reach their 50th wedding anniversary
this July Howard is fully aware of the
massive good fortune that has come upon
him they moved to the warm in Phoenix
and in Santa Fe and they spend their
time there now they support the arts and
teach about them to anyone who has the
luck to know their company they have a
special interest in contemporary art and
Howard is on the board of the Phoenix
Art Museum they are life members of the
president's club if you go to Santa Fe
I'm now on behalf of them and without
the permission to ask everyone of you to
invite everybody to go have dinner with
them because there isn't any better fun
to be had on the face of the earth
please come forward Howard and Jane
on behalf of the faculty in the board of
trustees of Hillsdale College it is my
privilege to present to you Howard and
Jan Hendler the honorary degree Doctor
of public service
[Applause]
Howard just said when I said that's
4,000 dinner guests he just replied I
can't wait so it's confirmed now he will
senior program a description of the life
of and works of Don Tibbets Potter she
is a funny generous and intelligent
woman she's just a complete hoot and she
couldn't be here I'm sorry so at last
you do not get to meet her but we will
carry her degree to her in California
our senior class president is Dina
Farhad she is just like all the other
officers of the senior class well
prepared to the point of annoyance
intelligence grateful constantly
Pleasant inspiring to know even that
grows a little annoying she has so much
of all that she'll be attending Michigan
State to study biology while she applies
for graduate school she was the
homecoming queen and not on looks alone
she is a moving force in Chi Omega and
everyone loves her Dina forehead
[Applause]
[Music]
dr. Arnn members of the Board of
Trustees distinguished guests fellow
graduates faculty staff family and
friends it is my honor to stand before
you today on this momentous occasion if
I may speak on behalf of my classmates I
must admit the last few weeks have been
quite chaotic we've experienced many
laughs we've attended our last
convocation played in our last game or
had our last recital
we've swiped into saga for the last time
left our mark on our senior sidewalk
we've submitted our theses had our last
chance for a ring before spring and for
them but most importantly for many of us
it was the last time we spent frantic
hours calculating the grades needed on
finals to get an A in the class now as
it is almost time to say our last
goodbyes I cannot help but look back at
the beginning of this journey I remember
it only as if it were yesterday that
beautiful sunny Sunday August afternoon
sitting in the very seats you're seated
in now it was the day of freshman
convocation much like today it was a day
of mixed emotions the excitement of
beginning a new chapter the nervousness
of leaving everyone and everything
familiar behind and the challenge of
beginning something difficult however
emotions and excitement aside there's
been one moment that has resonated with
me since that day as dr. Arnn was
addressing our class for the first time
he stopped to make a note to our parents
he said at some point your son or
daughter will say to you I'm excited to
go home however by home they will mean
Hillsdale at that moment I was I admit a
bit skeptical I thought how is it
possible for this little town in the
middle of nowhere or my barren dorm room
to become home
needless to say standing before you now
I find no better way to describe it I
know of no other place in which people
who were once strangers not only became
friends but family a place where
professors welcomed you not only into
the classroom but also their homes a
place where the administration gives not
only a friendly wave but knows your name
and the fact that you snuck into the
live
last night a place that has led us on a
path to our passions though not always
the easiest a place where the weather is
always changing but the smiles and
support are unwavering a place where
strength really does rejoice in the
challenge a place where for years just
doesn't seem like enough as we now leave
this home to embark on a new journey it
is our duty to take the knowledge and
principles that have been instilled
within us to go forth and be a light
upon men regardless of whether we make
that $25 donation or not
Hillsdale will always be home to us we
have many to thank for today our parents
who have allowed us room to grow in a
permanent place to call home and our
faculty for inviting us into their
home's
and making our cares theirs I'd like to
thank each member of the class of 2012
standing before you today I am humbled
by the chance to represent so many that
have done so much may God bless you and
all that you do till we meet again Neath
banners of white and blue I wish you all
the best
congratulations class of 2012
[Applause]
[Music]
when I have some my song
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was the superior and inspiring
Hillsdale College Chamber Choir under
the direction of James Holloman and
accompanied by Deborah wise
I appeal to the faculty that looked like
a whole lot of seniors in that group is
there any way yet to flunk them out so
they can come back next year will the
graduating class of 2012 please rise
upon the recommendation of the Faculty
of Hillsdale College and the affair and
with the authority vested in me by its
Board of Trustees I confer upon each of
you the degree for which you have been a
candidate and admit you to all the
rights privileges and responsibilities
to which you are entitled please be
seated
dr. Marino being a faculty will you
proceed
will the candidates in accounting please
come forward
[Applause]
dr. art dr. Arnn the conferring of
degrees is complete on behalf of the
Hillsdale College Board of Trustees I
congratulate the students of the class
of 2012 I also thank the parents
extended families and friends who are
here today and for your support of
Hillsdale College over these past four
years
your role is never far from our minds
and we are grateful for it the stay is
always a special one for the Board of
Trustees it is great to be on campus and
to see the results of your four years of
hard work many of us have watched our
own children across this very stage some
of us have crossed it ourselves I wish
each of you the best all the best as you
go from this place to cultivate your
education careers families and
businesses I hope that he will return
often to your alma mater or as your
class president so eloquently put it
your home congratulations
god bless
as no doubt you can see we are so very
proud of our graduating seniors
graduated seniors I should say a few
housekeeping notes in just a minute a
reception in honor of our graduates will
begin in the Guru Kok Student Union
which is directly behind us but first I
asked all of you to please stand in just
a moment
we will join with the choir in singing
the alma mater please do remain in your
seats until the procession has passed
but before we begin with the alma mater
I can say this to our seniors hats off
to you it's a tough act to follow
we see of college halls racing ha ha ha
[Music]
ha and I was nauseous
[Music]
the greatest ride lasting friends are
[Music]
sweet you like salsa here main are you
for the Charlotte Smith movie caramel
sauce
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and now may the Lord bless you and keep
you may the Lord make his face to shine
upon you and be gracious unto you may
the Lord lift up his countenance upon
you and give you his peace both now and
evermore
amen
[Music]
[Music]
be
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you